There was a time when we felt like we
had to justify all this nerdy sh*t to the outside world.
A time when we had to tell people that the accelerated growth of gaming was worth paying attention to.
Blizzard even paid Mr. T to plead our case.
"I'm Mr. T and I'm a night elf mohawk, what's your game." "World of Warcraft."
We were reaching outside of our little gaming
ecosystem to show people that this stuff was worth taking seriously.
That geeks weren't just basement-dwelling
weirdos to get people to just play games and join a growing culture. And by now
we all know how the rest of the story goes.
Real professionals are being paid millions to play, to entertain, and to build this industry into something that
rivals other forms of media. And now we don't even have to reach outside.
Because our celebrities are pushing the product better than anyone.
All you have to do is type Twitch.tv into your browser
Twitch streamers are our commercials.
If you're a developer looking to generate buzz about your new game
look no further than Ninja, Shroud or DrDisrespect. These guys sell games in our world.
They're our Hollywood celebrities while the esports stars are the athletes.
We don't have to look very far into the past to find concrete examples of what I'm talking about.
On August 21st Samsung collaborated with Ninja to create hype around their newest phone.
"Samsung Galaxy Note 9, beautiful.
Oh this is good. This is clean."
It's not Samsung's first foray into esports or gaming.
But another example of the kinds of stars companies are looking to to sell their products in 2018.
Ninja and the hype he generates is proof that streamers can be a great marketing weapon.
Just look at what happens when he decides to stream a new game.
A few months back when the fortnight servers were down,
Ninja in TimTheTatman, gave a new Battle Royale game a try. Realm Royale.
(Stream)
To say this fateful stream was huge for Realm Royale would be a massive understatement.
During June 2018 when Ninja first streamed the game and then subsequently played it a few more times,
Realm Royale jumped from an average of 21 of viewers in May to more than
25,000 average viewers every day. And then in July when Tim and Ninja's interest in shooting chickens dwindled,
so too did people's interest in watching the game which dropped to just over 6,300 average viewers.
The same impact was also felt by surging first-person shooter Rainbow Six Siege after
Shroud was banned from playing PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds,
During July 2018 When shroud wasn't able to play PUBG on stream, he took up Siege.
(Stream)
During that month, the game saw its highest average concurrent viewership since its release.
With more than 17,600 viewers. A jump of
5,000 average viewers over the previous month.
Now of course Siege was already a big name and a game that was on an upward trend.
But it's hard to overstate exactly how much it means when someone as loved as Shroud
is playing your game on stream.
And Ubisoft recognizes the value those influencers bring.
They've created a program to reward a long time streamers with special unique in-game
cosmetic items. Charms that offer incentives for viewers to sub to those channels
This has been the case with other games like PUBG.
Bluehole has rewarded players who have stuck with the game for a long time like Shroud and DrDisrespect with
personalized in-game cosmetics to help build their brand alongside the game.
Now obviously the relationships between these streamers and these smaller games
aren't always as organic as Ninja finding a new Battle Royale and enchanting his viewers or
Shroud styling on people in yet another competitive FPS.
This was specifically prominent with Sea of Thieves which averaged roughly
20,000 viewers at a time during January and March of 2018, while streamers like Shroud and Summit1g
were playing the game.
Since that time streaming numbers have dwindled to between one and two thousand over the last few months.
It's pretty simple. If you want your game to be popular at least on Twitch,
These personalities are gonna have to do this weird
public vetting for you. Because a lot of gamers want to play what the big streamers are playing.
just like celebrities and fashion or
athletes and footwear. They decide what's cool.
Now there is a flip side to this conversation.
From a streaming standpoint playing games that are outside of your brand or
outside of the mainstream can be a death knell for your viewership numbers.
A lot of the time the biggest streamers are known for the games they play.
And aside from Summit and Shroud
playing games outside of that can hurt your viewership and revenue.
This creates this push and pull in the streaming world where publishers are looking
to these top streamers to market their game.
But the streamers have to find a way to stay on top while doing so. Take Shroud and Rainbow Six
for example.
During July he may have spiked Siege's viewership and shown a lot of people just how cool the game is.
But his personal average viewership dropped by
about 6,000 at the same time. Throughout the previous three months
he hovered around 40K. While in July he averaged just over 33K.
So despite his ability to carry Rainbow Six any of the popularity PUBG holds that was carrying Shroud
disappeared. And honestly Shroud is probably less affected by this.
After all he's known for streaming multiple games.
Someone like Ninja whose popularity has been built around Fortnite, at least recently, has been met with stark
reactions to his decision to branch out.
His average viewership when playing Realm Royale over Fortnite dipped for more than
108,000 to roughly 63,000
That's more than 40,000 people tuning out at least in part due to a game change. Gamers can be fickle man.
(Stream)
Since Twitch's and livestream's explosion.
There's been a lot of conversation about exactly how far it can go.
As this generation of stream viewers become adults
can Twitch eclipse television? If that's the case,
then these heroes we've chosen to stand atop Twitch become even more
important to how the people on the outside and non-endemic sponsors view gaming.
We now know that streamers can bring more eyes to new games.
The real question is how those games and the larger gaming community can capitalize on it.
Games like Realm Royale, Sea of Thieves, Gwent and Shadowverse,
have all shown peaks on Twitch when the biggest streamers showed interest.
But where are they now? Maybe we're learning that this world isn't just about the games.
It's about the people playing them.
(Stream)